[Music]
let's take a look at this one this is
your 2010 hold on a second sorry cannot
have bird [ __ ] on the car it's not the
acid and bird [ __ ] that eats the clear
cut what happens is is the clear coat in
your paint constantly expands and
contracts with weather it expands and
when it contracts it contracts over it
and it embeds it into your so we're
that's how you get that stain in there
that's your lesson on bird [ __ ] for the
day hi everybody
my name is Kenny Wayne Shepherd welcome
to my house and come check out the
lounge of cars and guitarists hey Kenny
how are you I'm good how's it going all
right thanks for inviting me over I'm
real excited about checking out your car
collection today what is the love affair
with the General Lee there was a
lifelong childhood dream for me to be
behind the wheel of the General Lee from
speaks of hazard and the car just seemed
to be indestructible it always seemed to
be able to outrun the cops I'm a big fan
of drag racing and you have your most
recent car I guess is your dodge
lightweight yeah it's like a modern
version of factory-backed drag cars from
the mid 60's so it's a 64 dodge 330 the
factory made lightweight versions of
those cars with aluminum front ends they
specifically built those cars to mop up
the track with any of the competition
that wanted to step up let's go take a
look at few more cars all right Kenny
this is your 2010 Dodge Challenger SRT
guys that are real particular Mopar fans
and they know the Challenger well what
they may not realize is this is a 2010
with a 2012 front end on it you can pull
them off and put new ones on it's almost
like getting a new car
let's take a look at your duster yeah
now this is probably my favorite car out
of all of them and it certainly has the
most miles on it and Battlestars it's
got a lot of personality in the front
with it with a little dings and the
chips and everything else that's been
happening on these road trips here you
can't be a musician without having a
killer car audio system in this thing as
well right kick your car stereo put this
together this thing sounds as good as it
looks as killer as this audio system is
the real sound of this so it has to be
the engine yep
what do you say you fire it up for us
yeah he woke up the neighbors Kenny
thank you again so much for inviting us
in your home you have such a great
collection of cars guitars your love
affair for music and how it translates
to the cars that you drive I think is
really really wonderful
subscribe to GQ and let us know what you
want to see on car collectors